a select group of Nations are combined  to become the world's core security the  United States Russia China France and  the United Kingdom join forces we will  not allow our freedom to fade in the  darkness  rise up I've got stuff where at all we  got this  your guys are doing  getting back let's get our man  war room guys this would be brief the  CIA released a video to us Western world  what I saw  they're making compact dirty bombs that  have a much bigger impact worth watching  you don't come out on top for nothing  finished you got a mean three klicks  north northeast I'm ordering Predator  drones into the area now if things  should get out of hand we're gonna put a  Hellfire missile on his head my men will  be on the ground it'll be my call and  one that I have to live with so rough  copy you're clear sorry  like to end up filling up  there we go  your lives at risk with a Smuggler's  promising  we have to go target acquired  fire  you  you